hello and welcome to this video playing
do car let's see I've got a good rating
at the mode so and close to that magic
mark yeah usually I fail had this kind
of situations but maybe this is better
this time yeah he avoids the most
interesting move but I'm not really an
expert so I goes back ok surprising but
he gives me this big center here I would
have expected a caption instead ok you
five already this is very sharp stuff
not probably probably this a bit early
c5 interesting I can take go 45 jam
let's say I can take a player 5 he has
to take with the beep on d take this a 5
24 resins so auntie i geti five and
they're not sure this was the best
continuation but it's it's it's it's
certainly playable should be a slightly
better structure while ok probably here
and castles
yeah I'd like to go 94 so i will have to
take it him pretty clear and now wait
where to put the pieces this looks right
looking at those pond squares c76 be
eight okay so look you one kind of novel
yeah interesting question now how to how
to play it's a convenient position but
it's not quite clear how any serious
progress is to be made 9 p-5 is
definitely an option I think I'll go for
that trying to annoy him with Bishop c7
ideas and if it takes okay I've got my
my bishop am and also potential with a 4
a 5 on the queenside
okay so he basically says go ahead so is
he sacrificing star is he taking with
the bishop now no this one okay so
Bishop c7 the screen b7 that doesn't
really help a lot so okay this is not so
bad for him then and I just stopped back
going to be seven maybe
seems like a useful move anyway it's not
so easy to find a concrete way forward
yeah do I want to trade here not sure
about it and I can i'm a bit behind all
the clock so i don't want to take much
longer here I Scott rook the eight I
didn't even see that move not good
I didn't see Luke the aid coming that's
annoying if I clay the Queen takes takes
it takes on before
question is can sacrifice probably not
Queen d8 I mean hmm doesn't do it
surprising
okay those this majority should be quite
good I don't threaten anything here
though I simply forgot that the bishop
before is covering the Queen on b7 so I
don't have a threat here well it's
probably not so bad
difficult for him to not treat Queens
now
is taking a long time you or disappoint
okay takes now this one yeah I was
thinking that be five would be very
dangerous but maybe I'm wrong yeah yeah
I understand but my be point is also
very quick and isn't it
wow wow wow okay be somebody will take
this should be five doesn't help Bishop
a six might be a move time morning let's
see about this
if you move the rook then be seven takes
takes you to i have oxy seven so i think
i'm stopping the pawn
some p 7 now they can go see 267
it doesn't doesn't really help I guess
ok we'll see check yeah I've got this
stop now check check check check check
I'm not so quick lat where's that
totally doable ah tough game tough game
somehow let's let's have a look down
yeah I will looked a couple of things
it's probably questionable if d take c5
is really the right right choice Oh e5
just wins ok ok you five wins the game
just winced the peace with Queenie for
how stupid yeah thing is this is this is
very obvious win something like this 24
windsor luke and I saw the idea but
somehow I didn't think of just playing
it immediately this is winning a piece
and if black goes back again yeah I can
do this this and black resigns so that
would have been the punishment for
blacks opening play ya hear Black is
reasonably okay yeah Bishop f4 was
important to look at those important
squares but black is fine here miss no
big deal a six was good check basically
am yeah showing that my night be five I
didn't really need too much and black is
certainly okay here 94 yeah and now we
come to some some some shaky moments I
know 222 and he can go looked yet I
simply didn't have that on the radar at
all yeah no it's just awkward if I
played this he'll win this pawn and the
good structure on top so after Luke the
eighth i probably have to check and play
this and try to hold this position there
are some chances to hold it but it's
obviously not what white is playing for
and I still didn't see the idea rook t8
again even though now i have bishop t6
which is not that's what I didn't see
that but the computer now points this
out and Bishop g4 Bishop c5 at Bishop f2
now this this is probably not lost for
white but tough I have some chances with
the pawns yeah I wasn't trouble him and
now everything's okay again I have to be
five it gets very risky for black but he
very quickly decided on that and I feel
like I should be better now now the
engine wants to play five now breaking
this diagonal after this and probably
winning yeah I'm winning now even though
she too was a lot tougher he said and g5
Wow rook c8 be sure to be 70 Jack funky
ender nine and now this
Wow
hmm unsure of white kenwyn I can try to
get on the seventh-ranked like some
somehow I mean okay not blundering the
rook have to somehow get on the seventh
and try for this this kind of thing
tough tough and after this is probably
losing him yeah no it's a plus plus
three for White yeah very tough game we
had this route da them and that would
have given him a good game okay thanks
for watching